that's all i got
[Music]
so malignant is a horror movie by
director james wan the movie stars
annabelle wallace i don't remember her
character's name don't ask me to google
it or imdb it i don't have the energy
not for this like there are movies it's
like i should take the time this isn't
one of them anyhow she's getting visions
of these killings this very mysterious
brooding almost ghostly figure is
killing people first of all i felt the
lead annabelle wallace the best part of
the movie uh she's probably aided and
helped out the fact that some of the
acting from the actors who played the
supporting characters
well some of them like when the movie
started out in the setup you know it's
showing this thing that happened in the
past and the acting was so cheese i was
like okay this is gonna be one of those
scenarios where it's a movie within a
movie but it's not it's actually what
happened yeah i know imagine my surprise
i was like oh so that they were just
like perfect those are the takes and
that would definitely work out if the
movie felt more self-aware like it knew
what it was but it never feels like it
does there are movies out there that
totally nail the self-aware thing
and so the cheese kind of works with it
this movie doesn't have that this movie
feels like it wants to throw back to
older horror movies and older horror
genres but doesn't throw back far enough
it's not the 70s it's not thrown back to
the 80s not throwing back to the 90s no
mid-2000s this mid-2000s horror
throwback not that the mid-2000s didn't
have some standouts you know some fun
slasher flicks in there but
of all the places like there are some
cool things that happen in this movie
like the last act of the movie kind of
becomes an action movie
and it is stylish you're like oh
it's pretty sweet throwdowns happening
it also has elements from another
stephen king story i have to be vague
because if i tell you the premise of the
stephen king story i'm thinking of
you're gonna be like oh
i know the premise of this movie which
this movie is actually really
predictable not too far into it i was
like okay i'm pretty sure this is what's
happening and this is what's happening
and i may be off a little bit but i get
the general gist of what's happening
maybe it's because i know of the stephen
king story it totally reminded me of
that i'm being completely vague about
but i have to be vague like it's kind of
like wonder woman 1984 when i said oh
the end of this movie the last act
reminds me of a jim carrey movie because
i didn't want to say well it reminded me
of bruce almighty because then you'd
know what happens in the last act of the
movie you know it's all about wishes and
all that it's the same thing here so
this movie starts out as a ghostly
feeling james one-ish horror movie then
it becomes a mystery movie that's not
that mysterious and not that compelling
because you kind of piece it together
before the cops do and then the last act
turns into more action than anything
bloody actually like this movie is
actually pretty bloody not like it's
inventive it's not like total fatality
style where you're like oh the spine and
you know the chest rips none of that but
no cut away on the stabbings to the face
and the blood flying and it's in here
but there is a point in this movie where
you're gonna make this face you're gonna
go
okay and it's unavoidable it's
undeniable it's a cool concept but it
was just executed in the most ridiculous
way possible which is why i say this
movie isn't as self-aware as it probably
should have been or at the very least
doesn't come across as self-aware as it
wants the audience to think or know what
it is as it stands this movie feels like
three different concepts like on the
round table discussion that we're like
okay we can execute these movies three
different ways do we want haunting movie
do we want supernatural investigative
thriller movie or do we just want mid
2000's horror slash bloody slash cool
cheese killing with the killer in the
action movie man my grammar my
vocabulary my execution it's off today
but i kind of don't care for this one
you can have an off day if you're
reviewing a movie like malignant it's
fine anyhow it's like they couldn't
decide they were like let's force them
all into one
malignant a movie that's ridiculous
enough to not easily forget but would
probably be a better time if you're
drunk yeah
what the [ __ ] all right so malignant
have you seen it what did you think
about it what's your favorite horror or
slasher movie from the mid-2000s
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you